apple just blew our minds at their
jam-packed spring-loaded event
where they blew through announcements
faster than ever before
like brand new air tags new software and
financial services
apple tv ipad and the new 24-inch imac
that vadim got
spot on in yesterday's video and more
but since they packed so much into just
one hour
they didn't have time to mention
everything including m1 mac
upgrades that i'm personally very
excited for so here's
every new product and upgrade apple
released but didn't mention
during their event let's start out with
some hardware
apple announced the upgraded apple tv 4k
with the a12 bionic processor
and 4k high frame rate support and with
that
a brand new remote which is likely even
more exciting
since people have been complaining about
the old one for years
this thing is made out of solid aluminum
and ditches the touch surface for a
click pad that doubles as a touch
surface
so you get the best of both worlds for
fast navigation
and new scrolling gestures so you can
easily find the perfect spot in a movie
as well as rearrange buttons with
universal remote support
now of course they announced that at the
event and they said it's gonna cost 179
for a 32 gigabyte model but what they
didn't mention
is that the remote is fully compatible
with the original apple tv
4k and even the 2015 apple tv hd
and they didn't say that you can
actually buy this new remote
by itself for 59
so there is no need to buy a whole new
apple tv kit
now if you do want to buy one but you
don't want the 4k model they also didn't
mention that this remote is coming
with the a8 equipped apple tv hd for 149
bucks but with that said i would
definitely spend the extra 30 bucks
for the a12 4k model now the next one
isn't
fully confirmed since the listings
haven't yet went live
but with a really new cool magic
keyboard with the touch id built
in that comes with a higher end 24 inch
imacs those will likely be sold
separately and we can guess what the
price will be as well
that is because apple mentioned in fine
print that you can get this keyboard as
an
option for the base model new imac now
the current magic keyboard comes in at
99
so this one will definitely cost more
due to the needed
extra sensors and the secure enclave
encryption chip
but there is no way that it will cost
any more than say a hundred bucks
extra because then the base price would
be way too close
to the 1499 higher tier imac once you
add the additional
keyboard option so it will likely cost
149 dollars to 199
and at that price point it could be
worth it for easy multi-user sign in
for apple pay for authentication and
siri autofill
the big question is if apple will wait a
bit to offer it standalone like with the
imac pro keyboard
or if they will allow it to be used on
m1 max or any t2 equipped max let me
know in the comment section if you'd be
willing to pay
149 bucks or even 199 dollars
for this new touch id enabled keyboard
now for those of you who don't care for
a built-in stand that isn't height
adjustable
even though apple didn't mention it
there is thankfully a vasa mount
capable 24 inch four and a half k imac
available to order
now apple has a special page for these
and they don't come
with the stand included so it doesn't
seem that you can swap the regular stand
for a vase amount like you can on the
imac pro
instead it looks like the vase amount is
built in so you'll want to make sure
that you buy
this specific one if you need it prices
are exactly the same as the regular 4.5
k
imac so you won't save anything but
thankfully it won't cost you any extra
either
and there's no risk to the mount messing
up like it did for many users online
with the imac pro and now for what i am
personally most excited about
and that is improvements to the m1 mac
mini
when apple announced the m1 mac mini
last year it was a jaw dropping machine
coming in at only 699 dollars and
packing way more performance than a
similarly equipped intel one
that costs over twice the price both in
cp performance and especially in
graphics performance people
were shocked even though it was the
cheapest m1 machine it also performed
the best
and ran the coolest as well but there is
one big problem for many mac mini lovers
that stopped them from upgrading and
that's the fact that the 10 gigabit
ethernet option was no longer
available if you chose an m1 equipped
mac mini
that meant that you had to use a pricey
adapter to get 10 gigabit ethernet
and one of your ports were gone and with
that they run hot
often with loud fans and they aren't
reliable as
built-in ones either well thankfully
during apple's event
they went ahead and added 10 gigabit
ethernet options to the m1 mac
minis even to the base spec 1 which is
amazing
this means that we can now use one to
replace our imac pro
since we need the 10 gigabit ethernet
port to connect to our fast media server
and since the 24 inch imac doesn't have
this option
this means that the mac mini is the only
current m1 mac that has it
we previously expected 10 gigabit
ethernet in an upcoming
m1x mini but we weren't certain but we
now know that the more powerful
upcoming macs including the 28 or 30
inch imac
will have this option which is great
that also means that you can have
a super powerful and completely silent
machine
that costs as low as 799
with this really fast and consistent
wired connection
the next things the apple didn't
announce were brand new accessories
along with the brand new magic keyboard
and white apple has new cases
for the iphone 12s we have amethyst
capri blue
cantaloupe and pistachio color options
for apple silicon cases
and if you're into the leather cases
there is one new color
deep violet if you're like me and you go
caseless
but with a wallet for the convenience
and extra grip apple is also offering
theirs in this new
deep violet color we also have new
accessory colors for ipads with the
smartfolio and smart covers now
available in white
mallet green and electric orange and the
mini cover
only comes in the latter two new color
options
along with that we have new colors for
apple watch bands
and a completely new band as well if
you're a fan of the braided solo loop
like i
am we have new pistachio and electric
orange colors
and for the standard loop we also have
that pistachio color
but also cantaloupe and tamales blue
options
for the basic sport band we have that
cantaloupe as well as mallard green and
capri blue
and for the nike sport bands apple added
chlorine blue and green
iron stone and black and hasta with
light
options the one brand new apple watch
band
is a little crazy for me both in looks
and in price tag
and that's because it's a hermes branded
one called
jumping single tour it comes in at a
massive 319 dollars for a band
made out of textile woven nylon and is
available in five colors which i don't
want to pronounce
but they're all very vibrant and apple
says that they seem to jump
off the wrist of the wearer it also
seems like we have some new colors for
other hermes watch bands but i can't
confirm if these came out today
since i don't follow these 500 watch
bands
next is a brand new color for apple's
beats studio 3
over-the-ear headphones which launched
way back in 2017
but feature active noise cancellation
and the w1 chip
now available in the limited edition
neon green color
in collaboration with cycleworld and
rapper don toliver
for 349 bucks and lastly
there is one more change to ipads this
year the apple
wasn't fully clear about they mentioned
that we now have 5g support which is
great
since speeds and reception are much
better but they didn't say
that they hiked up the price for the
modem enabled
models it used to cost 150 to get
an lte ipad but it now costs 200
so 50 is more than before making a base
ipad pro with 5g
now 1 000 and that sucks for people who
may not even have 5g in their city or
country
we're making an in-depth video comparing
the new 2021 ipad pros compared to the
previous 2020s so click that circle
above
if you want to check that out and to
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers before the end of 2021
and check out another great video right
over there thank you guys for watching
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]